[Music]
straight ahead on Von crime daily the
Sandy Hook defamation trial we gave each
other a big hug and a kiss
and I left for work and
can't think of a better way to
if it had to go that way I can't think
of a better way your emotional testimony
from a shooting victim's husband and the
North Dakota love triangle tribe right
to the right of it in the photograph
it's a big gaping womb the pellets then
actually continued their course through
the arm into the left side of the head
fractured the face fractured the skull
jurors here from the medical examiner in
the murder conspiracy case of Nikki Sue
Ensign plus the Pike County Massacre
jurors are shown a piece of evidence
that helped link the murders to the
Wagner family but first the courtroom
gets heated as Waukesha Christmas parade
suspect Daryl Brooks seeks to represent
himself you are being difficult you are
not listening
you are trying to interject the
irrelevant factors long crime daily
covering court cases home Coast to Coast
welcome everyone to lawn crime daily I'm
your host Brian buckmeyer we begin with
news out of Wisconsin where a Waukesha
County Judge rules accused parade killer
Daryl Brooks can represent himself at
the coming trial
officials say that Brooks drove his
vehicle into a Christmas parade last
November killing six people and injuring
dozens of others prosecutors Say Brooks
did not stop driving even as victims
banged on the hood of his vehicle
motioning for him to stop now he faces a
total of 77 charges related to the
incident including six counts of
homicide by a vehicle hit and run
involving death first degree recklessly
endangering safety use of a dangerous
weapon battery domestic abuse and bail
jumping right now Brooks's trial is set
to begin next Monday ahead of that
Brooks indicating he wants to defend
himself as a sovereign citizen things
got tense when Brooks appeared in court
on Tuesday
sir did you hear me tell you about the
penalties for these offenses
yes but I don't understand the nature of
the cause of the church sir did you hear
me tell you about the penalties for
these offenses just now
make sure it causes the charges I'm not
asking you that sir did you hear me
advise you of the penalties for hit and
run resulting in death
did you hear me tell you about the
penalties for hit and run resulting in
debt
I don't understand the nature and the
cause of the charges but that's not my
question sir so stop playing games with
me right now okay
Judge Jennifer Darrow did not make a
ruling on Tuesday calling for Brooks to
meet with his attorneys before another
appearance Wednesday morning Brook says
mother sent the judge a handwritten note
reading in part quote he's not capable
of being his own attorney how can a
person who has a mental illness fully
understand before judge Darrow made her
ruling on Wednesday Brooks once again
got argumentative as questions were
asked
this trial will start
next Monday
October 3rd
did you hear me say that
I heard you say it but I object to that
and I object on the grounds that are you
making a Judicial determination of that
when you haven't even decided
the issue while we're here
sir I further going to advise you that
at this late stage in the proceedings
which is frankly beyond the 11th Hour
which is what the case law references we
are frankly at 11 58.
this court will not appoint any other
attorney
to act
as standby Council
if this court grants your request to
represent yourself
did you hear me say that sir
is that the answer to the question sir
did you hear me
just now
is that an answer to the question this
is not a question and answer session sir
I'm giving you certain advisements
did you hear me advise you
just now
there's a question I asked because it
sounds like Mr Brooks will move on you
are advised Mr Brooks you are advised
that this court will not appoint standby
Council okay there are a number of
reasons which I will advise you make it
impractical
if you don't answer the question
joining us today is legal analyst Dina
Dahl and co-host Terry Austin Tina did
the judge make the right call should
Brooks be able to represent himself pro
se
yeah when you
when he's attorney and that they can't
afford it can be appointed to them they
also have the right to represent
themselves but representing yourself
means that you have to follow the same
rules of procedure the same rules of
evidence that every other lawyer does
just because you're representing
yourself doesn't mean you get a free
pass not to know the law so it's a huge
uphill battle especially in a case like
this and that interaction it certainly
seemed like he wasn't confident to be
able to represent himself because he
didn't even seem like he could
understand you know the issues that she
was saying there yeah well sir what
exactly is a sovereign Citizen and when
he was asked as we saw just there in a
few Clips do you do you understand or
did you hear do you think that Brooks
really understood the charges or was he
just playing games oh he was definitely
playing games a sovereign citizen it's
someone who believes that they're not
subject to any sort of governmental law
or proceeding unless they consent so
they don't believe in paying taxes they
don't believe that courts have
jurisdiction over that and so he is
playing a game here which is one of the
reasons if I had been that judge would
say you need counsel because she's going
to have a trial of the century where
it's going to be this back and forth so
he seems like a relatively intelligent
guy he's been involved with the criminal
justice system in the past he
understands what she's saying or he
should because he's been involved before
so he's just making it very difficult
for himself and for the court it's going
to be a very very interesting trial to
watch make sure to follow it at
lawncrime.com
and in Florida the penalty phase trial
for the Parkland school shooter recess
is because of inclement weather due to
Hurricane in the shooter is facing the
death penalty or life in prison after
pleading guilty to the Parkland schools
shooting in which the then 19 year old
gunman killed 17 and injured 17 others
and Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School
on Valentine's Day in 2018. following
just two days of testimony this week the
court decided to close Wednesday and
Thursday due to Hurricane Ian which made
landfall in Florida as a strong Storm
Friday was already a scheduled day off
in the case so testimony won't resume
until next Monday
still had on Law and crime daily we head
to North Dakota as Witnesses testimony
begins in the murder conspiracy case of
Nikki suenson as she faces trial for her
role in the shooting death of her
husband but first key evidence is shared
in court in the Pike County Massacre
trial out of Ohio tying George Wagner IV
to the crime scene
[Music]
welcome back jurors in the trial of
George Wagner IV see one of the first
pieces of evidence that prosecutors say
linked the Wagner family to the murders
of the rodents and Hannah Gilly law and
crimes Anjanette Levy is here with
images of the evidence
well Brian's shoe Impressions were
collected from a couple of the crime
scenes and then sent to a trace evidence
examiner at the State Crime Lab take a
look at these These Are The Impressions
that were collected in blood at the
crime scenes Suzanne Elliott who
examined the impression said they were
enhanced using chemicals she couldn't
find the tread pattern from those shoes
in two databases so she went shopping
Elliott said she went to several stores
before finding shoes with the tread
pattern at Walmart in which she called
an aha moment Elliott said the shoe
Impressions at the crime scenes came
from the sizes ten and a half and an 11
size shoe which were both left at the
crime scenes now you may be asking
yourself why does any of this matter
well after Elliott identified those
shoes as coming from a Walmart store BCI
agents submitted subpoenas to Walmart to
all the Walmarts within a 50-mile radius
of where the crimes were committed they
got back receipts and also surveillance
video that showed all of these people in
that area buying these Walmart shoes and
Angela Wagner George Wagner's mother was
one of the people buying those shoes
days before the murders she is expected
to testify about that later in the trial
Brian thank you imagine that Terry this
almost sounds like a true crime version
of Cinderella but how strong is the
connection between Wagner and the shoe
Impressions especially when the
prosecution has no actual shoe well you
know it definitely would be stronger for
the prosecution if they had those actual
shoes but the jury can connect those
dots if you have the impression and
Kudos by the way to the agent who found
that Walmart footage and who found the
receipts because if you have the shoe
Impressions and you have the receipts
and you have the video evidence of
Angela purchasing those shoes then all
you have to do is put it together why
else would she be purchasing men's shoes
in those sizes so I think the jury it's
like having a gun and bullets and making
the dots when you are able to connect
that gun to those bullets when you
bought the bullets you bought the gun
you might not have the gun but all in
all I think the jury is going to be able
to figure it out with or without those
shoes yeah but but that's an important
part and the interesting part as well
because Dina this testimony all seems to
depend on Angela Wagner testifying right
so is it smart to stack such an
important part of the trial on a
cooperating co-defendant
I mean normally it's not that smart
because they can uh the defense attorney
can show that maybe the defend the
witness you don't got something in
return for their testimony as here like
some sort of reduced
um you know sentence but the fact is it
doesn't help that this is a family
member testifying against the defendant
and I think that goes against the idea
that maybe the witness is lying in order
to get a lighter sentence because
usually family members aren't willing to
testify against other family members and
here you have that all right well and
yet will another shoe impression expert
testify on the trial
yeah Brian his name is William bosiak
and he actually testified at a hearing
pre-trial it was called a dobbert
hearing to determine whether or not this
evidence really passed muster
scientifically and he is a really famous
guy he used to work for the FBI he
really wrote the book on shoe impression
analysis and he was the person who
tracked down those Bruno Bali shoes in
The Civil Trial for O.J Simpson in which
he was sued for wrongful death 20 some
odd years ago so he really knows his
stuff and is expected to back up the
assertions of Suzanne Elliott yeah it
looks like he left a good impression on
you Anjanette we'll see if he does the
same with the jury well coming up on Law
and crime daily plaintiffs in the Sandy
Hook defamation trial take the stand
saying Alex Jones's comments make them
fear for their safety plus graphic
photos of the victim are shown in court
as the medical examiner testifies in the
North Dakota murder conspiracy trial of
Nikki sulensel
foreign
[Music]
welcome back testimony begins in the
North Dakota murder conspiracy trial of
Nikki suenzel as jurors hear from
several witnesses on the first day
including the victims family members and
the medical examiner Ensel is charged
with conspiracy to commit murder among
other charges for her role in the 2019
shooting death of her husband Chad
investigators say Ensel was having an
affair with a man named Earl Howard
while she was still married they say in
late December of 2019 the pair conspired
to kill chat officials believe the
motive was money including a six hundred
thousand dollar life insurance policy
and a 26 thousand dollar property
insurance policy taken out just days
before the murder Howard previously pled
guilty to conspiracy and arson charges
investigators say the pair shot in the
head then days later started a fire at
the home which they believe was an
attempt to cover up the murder the
12-person jury heard key testimony from
the medical examiner who explained there
were no signs Chad was alive when the
fire started
so the shotgun wounds that he had
if he would have gotten medical
attention would he have survived those
wounds no
why do you say that the entry to the
back of the head behind the left ear was
completely devastating
caused multiple fractures in the skull
and it
as I say severely injured the brain was
there a way to tell if Chad died before
or after the fire began
well he um
he did not he he died after the fire or
died as the fire was starting because
had he died when the fire was in
progress he would have inhaled smoke and
we've been able to detect soot in his
Airway the same soot that was on his
body would have been in his bronchial
tubes and his windpipe and did not find
any of that
Terry how does how Chad dies play into
proving this was a conspiracy to commit
murder by two people and maybe not just
one which I'm guessing is ensel's
defense
well he died from gunshot wounds to the
back of the head so that means one
person pulled that trigger probably it
was only one type of gun so I do think
it supports what the defense is probably
going to say which is look it wasn't me
it was him and they don't have any
evidence that there was a beating with
multiple different types of weapons that
wasn't a different type of gun it was
the same type of gun but even if enzel
is able to say look I didn't do the
actual shooting she still has those
conspiracy charges so I don't think
that's really going to help her that
much it's just you know one thing that
she can point to to say it wasn't me it
was him yeah now Dina the Emmy testified
that Chad Ansel could not have survived
the shooting explaining he was shot in
the back of the head is that fact a win
for the prosecution
wait it's always helpful to the
prosecution when they can so
definitively have a cause of death
because as you see here there's you know
the less kind of options that a jury has
as to who did it like Terry was
mentioning for this her or the other man
you know that hurts and then the same
with cause of death whether or not it
was the fire whether or not it was a
shooting so it does help in terms of
their theory of the case for it to be
definitive as it is here how he died all
right we'll continue we'll continue to
keep track on this case as it progresses
when we come back the Sandy Hook
defamation trial we head to Connecticut
where jurors will soon decide how much
radio host Alex Jones owes in Damages
[Music]
welcome back to Long crime daily on day
10 of the Alex Jones defamation trial
jurors here from the husband of a Sandy
Hook school shooting victim in December
of 2012 a gunman opened fire on the
elementary school and Newtown
Connecticut six staff members and 20
students were shot and killed in the
Years following right-wing radio host
Alex Jones commented on the massacre
saying it was a hoax put on by crisis
actors as part of his second defamation
case 15 plaintiff Sue Jones saying his
remarks led to people tormenting the
family members of victims and
jeopardizing their safety Jones has
already been found liable for damages in
this case meaning jurors will now decide
how much he should pay on Wednesday
jurors heard from the husband of Mary
Sherlock the school psychologist who was
shot five times her husband William
Sherlock told jurors he feared for the
safety of his family after Jones
commented on the shooting
did there come a time uh
that you became concerned about
your safety and the safety of your
daughters and grandkids
yeah
um
there was enough vitriol out there that
I was concerned that
well let's put it this way okay so let's
let's move it back a little bit the
major crime unit from the state police
we had meetings with them periodically
and at the end of the meeting they would
always tell us be on guard be careful
about what you do make sure you know
where you are what's going on it's it's
been constant I mean that's never leaves
me at this point in time always aware of
what's going on around me
um introduce myself when I'm out and
about with people that I don't really
know and it's just my first name
Dina we're hearing rumors that Jones
won't be on the stand this week but is
his absence during the testimony a bad
look especially in front of the jury
always a bad luck when a defendant or in
this case the defense in a civil case
doesn't show up because the jury doesn't
want to show up either right they're
taking time out of their life and they
have to come and so it's definitely
disrespectful but they're not going into
liability which maybe could have hurt
him a little bit more I think the only
place where maybe this will come into
play is punitive is because punitives
you could almost think of as like a
sentencing version of the Civil versus a
criminal case it's where you take into
like deterrence and him not showing up
the jury might think he needs a higher
punitive award to deter him from taking
this action because he's not taking it
seriously by showing up yeah and it's
not like in other cases where the person
has no ability to reoffend he actually
does Terry as we listen to the
plaintiff's attorney doing their direct
examination on the family members are
there specific points being emphasized
no doubt about it I do think the
plaintiff's attorney is trying to weave
this sort of story with each and every
family member and each and every person
who gets up on that stand you know the
testimony is emotional no doubt about it
and he does want the jury to feel that
emotion and beyond that he definitely
wants to make sure that the jury knows
who those family members are where did
they go to school where did they grow up
how were they attracted to each other if
it's a husband and a wife but he also
wants to make sure that that jury
understands the victim so not only do
they explain themselves and what they're
going through but they explain those
victims those babies who were shot and
killed at the ages of you know six and
seven and so he makes sure that the jury
hears that and that each of those family
members tell the story about their
individual child and while their child
was very special and basically you know
when the families learned about Alex
Jones that's one thing the plaintiff
needs to make sure the jury understands
how was it you heard about the hoax what
was the effect of that hoax on you how
did it affect you emotionally physically
financially and you heard the story so
Alyssa Parker and Robbie Parker told
about how it affected them and it was
powerful absolutely agree wholeheartedly
in all of that well Dina Terry thank you
very much and thank you for joining us
here on Law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss Justice in
America
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]